[Music]
you have probably heard of blockchain
the buzz around blockchain blockchain
blockchain is the backbone of
cryptocurrencies the central transformed
many aspects of our lives
this is probably the place you might
think it is changing the game the
financial sector
what if i told you it can do even more
the blockchain revolution is brewing but
it's not where you think it is
in this two-part special i meet the
farms
the grocers i want to show you something
more interesting
on the fish
and the startups so what do you need in
the physical world is actually iot the
internet of things
trying to change the world of food with
blockchain now imagine if you could know
exactly how many steps this free-range
chicken took during its lifetime
can the technology behind cryptocurrency
really help us know our food
i get a taste of blockchain and why
matters
[Music]
the world is getting crazier
more complicated
so i'm back to help you make sense of it
all
this time i'm bringing you greater
access
more engaging stories and deeper
insights i'm going to tell you why it
matters
so what is blockchain
to put it simply it's a giant ledger
that tracks the exchange of assets like
money or goods between two or more
parties
imagine all these are digital
and are kept on not just one computer
but on many computers
like its name suggests information about
transactions are stored in virtual
containers called blocks
these blocks are digitally chained to
one another
this encrypted data is then made
available to all the computers on the
blockchain network
making it almost impossible to change
data that's been recorded
this breakthrough in data storage is
what experts believe will change the
world
i find out exactly how from dr julian
hosp author of cryptocurrencies simply
explained and so why we do this is so
that people don't work on things
that are not related to some business
reasons
julian is also co-founder of 10x a
singapore-based startup
it's just three years old
yet last year
10x was among the best funded startups
in the world
so here you can see part of our team um
our team is our asset
investors poured about 80 million us
dollars into its initial coin offering
buying into tennex's promise of making
cryptocurrencies spendable
so at the next we started a bit over
three years ago and we learned about
this thing called cryptocurrencies
bitcoin and so on and so we thought
all these virtual currencies how can we
use them in real life and so that's how
we started with a debit card that people
can connect to these cryptocurrencies
and then they can go to starbucks and
can go to these stores and they can
actually spend their bitcoin for coffee
what other applications are there for
blockchain technology all a blockchain
actually does is instead of me storing
information on a company server i can
store this information on myself and i
can prove that i have not tampered with
this information this is what blockchain
through cryptography allows how is that
different from other databases it means
censorship resistance
i no one can censor
what a new block looks like one of these
info blocks that get gets integrated and
no one can censor the past so i cannot
just remove or add something i cannot
block something so the censorship
resistance is very very powerful because
it doesn't allow one party to tamper
with something the second thing is
transparency
everyone can see the blocks from today
until the very beginning so this means i
can actually see what happened what was
the data flow a lot of the data is
anonymized so i cannot see who did what
that's fine but transparency in this
system is extremely high so i can
literally see in money did money get
created did money get destroyed how much
money did actually move i cannot see the
participants now obviously an
interesting application is finance
because i can store how much money i own
and everyone knows that i didn't change
the amount so yesterday i had ten
dollars today suddenly i have ten
thousand dollars so i couldn't do this
with blockchain so is the technology
very advanced right now but just not
widespread so i think at the moment we
are just dabbling around with testing
and seeing what's possible i think we
are
in the 1990s of the internet so really
20 years ago i think it's it's trying
it is this gonna work would a user do
this i think it's really early stage
right now i think it's it's really great
for for enterprises for governments to
to look into this create sandboxes
create accelerators and just kind of no
one knows exactly what are going to be
the killer use cases in the future so i
but i think we're testing and we're in a
really really really early stage right
now if a country doesn't invest in
blockchain will they lose out in the end
i think a government that doesn't invest
in blockchain is is going to lose out
it's just like not investing into online
you would have lost out over the past 20
years
with blockchain there's a lot of other
really great applications i'm very very
convinced over the next 20 years we're
going to see it in all our lives
it turns out blockchain may well start
turning up sooner than we think in one
of the great pleasures of our lives
food
i'm here at food and hotel asia a
biennial food and hospitality event
aside from food to tickle my taste buds
the event also gave me food for thought
and a talk on food provenance
how do we know where our food comes from
and how do we ensure that information
cannot be faked
i think that
blockchain technology has an incredible
application to provenance to ensuring
that
what we see on a label
is actually what we're going to be
eating or drinking we believe that one
of the best
use cases for blockchain technology is
the supply chain
i caught up with the speaker max
cantilia after the talk
max is co-founder of untrained capital a
technology company that specializes in
building private blockchains for
international companies
as someone who enjoys fine wine and food
he's excited about the potential
application of blockchain on food
so blockchain technology is always
associated with cryptocurrency yes
why food industry then
blockchain is a wonderful solution to
looking at trust and transparency in
that entire supply chain from the pig
farmer through to the table that's
because the blockchain allows us
to make
every transaction transparent and
available to every participant
in that chain and so what's on that
label there for example can be entered
into the chain and it will be seen by
every participant on the chain so for
example if the technology was available
i could just take out my phone
and scan the label and it will tell me
exactly where this pick was from
when it was slaughtered etc even more
than that it will tell you how it got
distributed
from the farm to
a distributor how the distributor went
to a shipper
and it will even tell you which ship
this traveled on to singapore before it
came to the restaurant where you might
be eating it and you cannot possibly
tamper with the information along the
way
blockchain technology sounds like what
singapore coffee entrepreneur pamela
chung has been looking for
pamla runs a coffee academy and roastery
called better barista which trains and
employs disadvantage to women
ensuring her coffee beans come from a
sustainable source is part of the ethos
of a social enterprise
can ask where are the beans from
uh the beans we're using today uh
they're actually um single origin coffee
from myanmar myanmar yeah now is it
really very important for your customers
to know where coffee come from well i
think increasingly consumers are getting
quite concerned about the providence of
food right ingredients where
does our food come from you know
is it ethically sustainably sourced so
currently how do you know that your
beans are ethically sourced with this
myanmar coffee we actually have gone to
the farm we've talked to the farmers and
with our partners who are processing the
coffees there we try and see for
ourselves for example the conditions of
the farmers are good right
and make sure that your money gets to
them it's costly right now of course a
lot of time yes yeah so it is not an
endeavor that you know i think a lot of
people can afford to do so i think with
technology like blockchain where you
can't go in and alter the information
right
it i think gives us a little bit more
ability to be transparent and authentic
with that information along the way
with blockchain pamela will be able to
reassure her customers that her coffee
beans are ethically sourced
for example
to prove that she has compensated the
farms fairly they can scan a code which
can put beside her label to see if a
fair trade certificate has been issued
to her
this will give a company an edge over
its competitors
which is why today she is meeting with v
chain a blockchain technology developer
based in shanghai v chain made a name
for itself developing blockchains for
luxury brands such as renault
right now we try to make it more
accessible for everyone right so if
everyone has a smartphone then it's easy
to verify the origins of a product yeah
so if for instance you have a qr code
that is already embedded on your package
okay all i need is a smartphone scan it
and then it's verifying you're able to
see a photo of the product yeah so you
assure that it is the right product and
the most exciting part is here
so you're able to see the time and date
every event has occurred in the supply
chain and who was part of it okay so
this makes your supply chain very
visible once that event has occurred
it's on the blockchain and you can never
change it right so somebody i can't go
in and just you can manipulate that data
got it so as a consumer i i now can
trust that what you say is true that
it's really from myanmar
this is the day that it left your
warehouse and this day it's made to
roast so i think that is something that
the blockchain can help reinforce that
you're not lying and what you put on
your marketing um whatever you claim
that you're doing it's true this is how
the blockchain can help you so i need to
find out from you like your processes um
is there any element of tech involved is
it all very manual for instance yeah
pretty much so i mean basically how it
works is that uh like we work with uh
genius coffee in myanmar so they run a
processing uh center in the shan
highlands and they work with you know
the few hundred uh smallholder farmers
there so during harvest time they will
collect all their cherries right and
bring them to the to the processing farm
and then genius and this team will
process it all that right and then it
finds its way onto a ship yeah the ship
comes to singapore
singapore we pick it up it goes into our
warehouse
and then when we're ready to roast it it
goes into our roastery
we roast the coffees right and we pack
it
into these bags for consumers
and then it goes out to all our retail
locations online okay so that's kind of
the chain okay yeah so what do you need
in the physical world is actually um iot
the internet of things smart devices
like um for instance a qr code maybe to
illustrate the a short chain we could
have my colleague go to your retail
store okay have it scanned and then
we'll bring it here and have it scanned
again just to showcase that the location
is being detected at two different
places so that means we're gonna put it
on the bag yeah we'll put a qr code on
the bag okay and we'll take it to the
shop at passes
and then have it scanned so the time and
the location should be reflected on the
blockchain
[Music]
[Music]
so as you can see the coffee bean has
arrived at plaza singapura okay and um
also it's open for brewing okay and
there's a time to it and there's also a
location to it singapore central oh yeah
can we get more specific because
actually in plaza singapore right which
is a specifics yes place yeah so for
demo purpose um we'll showcase singapore
east cinco central is very high level
yeah but of course if we work together
we can implement that for you very
easily um
exact coordinates okay
this can happen because that would be
more useful correct
the potential of what blockchain
technology can do for pamela goes beyond
traceability
in theory when a chain has been created
from farm to table a mechanism to pay
for a cup of coffee using cryptocurrency
can also be done
and because of the transparency of
blockchain provides as a consumer i can
actually track where my money goes
if i don't want to only tip the barista
but also support the farmer directly i
can do so
the application of blockchain on food
traceability is still relatively new in
singapore
but one country is going big with it
china
and that's where i'm heading
[Music]
according to a 2016 report by the u.s
chamber of commerce
china is responsible for about 86
percent of the world's counterfeit goods
that's about 400 billion us dollars
it's no wonder you can't tell fake apart
from real in china
but here the problem goes beyond high
street branded goods
into the food we eat
with counterfeit food
the bigger problem is of course food
safety
from adding melamine to milk powder to
passing off red meat as mutton
a slew of food scandals have rocked
china over the last decade
[Music]
since the infamous 2008 milk powder
scandal
china continues to be a hot bit for
contaminated and counterfeit food
[Music]
a pew research center study in 2017
found that 4 out of 10 chinese view food
safety as a very big problem
so you can imagine the extraordinary
demand for information regarding food
provenance here
because the stakes are life or death
so some food giants are stepping up
[Music]
one of them is jd.com
the retailer is going out of its way to
track as many of its goods as possible
right down to the farm using blockchain
technology
and i can access all of that
unadulterated information from the
comfort of my hotel room
a simple search on the popular chinese
retail platforms tells me that the
variety of products attract ranges from
packaged goods like milk powder
and wine
to livestock
like sea cucumbers
[Music]
jd is alibaba's biggest rival it is the
second largest e-commerce company in
china
it made its foray into online groceries
in 2012.
six years later it set up its first
brick and mortar store here at 7 fresh
in paintings e trung district
jd's flagship supermarket is 4 000
square meters big
many of its products are tracked on the
blockchain
you you notice there is a qr code in the
package i can
open the seven fresh abp and using the
scan function
to scan the qr code on the package
it shows me the where it comes from the
manufacturing company the farm
information this makes the supply chain
of the vegetable more visibility
[Music]
i want to show you something more
interesting okay
you can see there is also a color called
the face body color on the fish and then
i scan the qr code it gets me to the
detail information page okay you know
exactly where it came from and at which
date what time it was fetched and what
time it was tested
the grocery manufacturers association
estimates that a single food fraud
incident can cost the company 2 to
fifteen percent of its annual revenue
[Music]
for a massive firm like jd which netted
a total of fifty five point seven
billion us dollars in revenue last year
at two percent
that can translate to a loss of 1.1
billion dollars
so the fight against food fraud is
serious
they are even opening up their
blockchain to their suppliers and other
companies so they too can develop their
own blockchain applications for more
secure and transparent supply chain
management
former computer scientist professor dr
payton is leading the development of
this technology in jd
one of the most cited authors in the
field of big data dr pay has more than
25 years of academic expertise
when we say supply chain we know where
it is
but people have a hard time i mean you
know typical customers would have a hard
time to
touch or to see supply chain it's a very
dry concept you can't hold it you can't
you know hold on to something like that
yeah it's intangible yeah but through uh
these uh blockchain service the chasing
service now people can really
use the benefits of blockchain to enjoy
uh the
rich information collected in the whole
process was it not possible before
having blockchain technology because for
blockchain one advantage is that you can
have the information from multiple
parties
and those parties may not even know each
other meet each other or may not even
trust each other
so
blockchain
provides such a technique to facilitate
such a collaboration among different
parties in an infective and efficient
way
now imagine if you could know exactly
when these mushrooms were harvested
or if any pesticides were used on these
vegetables
or exactly how many steps
this free-range chicken took during its
lifetime
[Music]
but in china it already is a reality
[Music]
today
jd tracks 14 000 products from 500
brands on the blockchain
and one of the first livestock to be on
their blockchain
sea cucumbers
[Music]
i'm in a province of liaoning and around
me in the waters are millions of sea
cucumbers and you can see it for
yourself
what i mean is you can watch the
surveillance footage of one of the many
aquaculture farms here on chinese
e-commerce website jd.com
on the site what you see alternates
among the close to 100 cameras at random
sea cucumber suppliers senori long
seafood company chose to upload this
onto their blockchain
which is then displayed on jd's website
and mobile application
they do so because they want consumers
to verify the origin and authenticity of
their sea cucumbers for themselves
[Music]
why would a company go to such great
lengths to demonstrate provenance
i wondered about that until i realized
that a huge price difference exists
between sea cucumbers harvested from
different places
take these two cucumbers for example
they may look the same
but i soon find out that one costs 600
us dollars more than the other
okay we're here in a room specifically
for storage and preparation of sea
cucumbers which is a specialty of this
restaurant that has almost a 90 years
history in beijing and i'm also with
head chef aunt who has had 40 years of
experience with this restaurant
and from my limited knowledge of sea
cucumbers i know that the more spikes
there are on the sea cucumbers the more
expensive let me try to guess which is
the cheapest first all right so let me
go for the one with the least spikes
this one has pretty short spikes but
this one looks a bit shriveled and a bit
wrinkled i would say that this is the
cheapest it's quite obvious to me that
this sea cucumber has the most number of
spikes and the length of the spikes are
also quite long the longest out of all
the six types i see over here so i think
this should be the most expensive what's
higher therma
you are an expert in sea cucumbers but
how about their ordinary chinese folk
who go to the market and buy cucumbers
do they know as much as you do
i learned that premium sea cucumbers
from liaoning for example cost a pretty
penny because the waters they grew up in
are colder
[Music]
when it comes to fraud related to sea
cucumbers it is usually a case of
consumers being conned into buying those
of an inferior grade at premium prices
nobody dies
but people are understandably angry that
they are not getting the value they were
promised
[Music]
by putting sea cucumbers on the
blockchain
scenery long hopes to reassure their
customers that the sea cucumbers they
bought are worth every penny they paid
i'm meeting li shengshong from sinuilong
it is her job to make sure that each sea
cucumber produced by a company meets the
high standards expected by their
customers
what what do you choose to show their
consumers
issues
it sounds like a very transparent
process
until i find out the input of data onto
the blockchain is a manual one
so the possibility of human error
remains
so apart from the live stream of
surveillance footage why should i trust
the information
[Music]
i return to scenery long's blockchain
technology provider jd for answers
you know can i fix certain information
and put it on the chain is that possible
very very good question you have very
good insight into the
business
indeed this is a great opportunity for
technology for example we can use the
iot devices to collect some of the
information like a temperature like the
environment variables
and then record such information
directly into the blockchain i see so it
has to be like a machine process and not
a human not human yeah so there's a
whole infrastructure that is required
for the whole tracking system on
blockchain to be
[Music]
realized the internet of things or iot
refers to a network of connected devices
it is not only one of the big buzzwords
in business today
it is also changing our everyday life
today for a small price
you could already set up your smartphone
to connect to all of your electrical
devices in your home
to control the lights
play your favorite music here's a
spotify station featuring jazz
[Music]
so it feels just right when you get back
home
here's the catch it may not cost much to
make your home smarter but it will
likely cost tens of thousands to
automate even a small to medium
enterprise
who bears the cost because it does sound
like a costly venture and would the
consumer have to take up
most or part of that cost the cost of
building the first blockchain
application is typically expensive but
as long as you enlarge the application
domain scope
then you will average out the cost i see
so at the end the cost will be
uh low that is also why in the next five
years when blockchain technology becomes
the more standardization uh technique
than the cost will be lower
so far i found out that while blockchain
is encrypted it is only as reliable as
the data it feeds on
but even if the integrity of data is
assured what happens if the physical
product is compromised
the url still points to the same link on
the blockchain but the product is
compromised
bitcoin may hog the headlines but the
technology behind cryptocurrency can do
more
in china blockchain is being used to
trace food
what it means is you can access critical
information about food products using
this
a qr code or quick response code is like
a bridge
it connects the product which is in the
physical world with information in the
digital world
these patterns are readable only by
machines so when you scan a qr code the
machines translate that into information
which makes sense to us
there's also nfc near field
communication
nfc belongs to the umbrella of
technology called rfid radio frequency
identification
rfid uniquely identifies each item using
radio waves and for nfc data is more
securely transmitted via a higher
frequency using a chip
[Music]
blockchain startup v-chain is one of the
few in the industry that designs and
manufactures their own sensors this is
where we manufacture the our chips
different kinds of uh
tagging
tagging mechanism so here we have qr
codes this is the nfc chip you can wrap
it on the package when you open it you
will destroy the antenna and this one is
actually a new generation of like a two
in one chip in this chip you actually
have both rfid and nfc because it's very
easy it's very friendly to the
enterprises because and rfid is actually
very useful in the warehouse you can
scan it
from long distance and scan the products
in batch but at the same time rfid needs
special reader so for that for the end
consumer the rfid is not very easy to
use so when it arrives at a retail store
you can only use nfc so end consumer
they can just scan an nfc with their
cell phone so it's it basically means
the need different needs from for the
warehouse and
and the consumer
[Music]
so i understand there are different ways
to access a blockchain can you tell me
more about it right
it doesn't matter like qr code rfid or
nfc chip is just a way to tag the
product so we design different methods
based on the nature of the product and
also based on the value of the product
because
if you tag the product with the chip of
course the cost is higher than the qr
code so we are actually working a couple
other
like wine
wineries one producers they have some
high-end wine which is like over a
thousand
like rmb or something that makes it
makes sense to put like nfc chip on on
those products
this space is actually uh so this is a
the wine and you have the nfc chip here
it shows you how this nfc chip can be
placed so you use nfc chip to scan now
right now the app is verifying the
identity of this bottle
once it's been verified you can see what
why it is this is the unique id and if
you want to get more information you
have the product story
description and in the in the real world
you will also have logistic information
yeah
which technology will be your key to the
blockchain in the future the answer is
not obvious
consider this
now this
is a bottle
of a 2007 red wine from the famous wine
estate called chatu mutton ross trial
from bordeaux france
if it is what it says it is it costs a
whopping 900 us dollars
if it isn't
well take a heart that you're probably
not alone because it is one of the most
counterfeited wines in china
one would expect the distributor of such
rare wines
the state-owned direct imported goods or
dig
to go with nfc technology which is more
secure and
customizable
but that's not the case
so what are we looking at here so you
could easily find when uh and also the
wine come from which winery oh so it
also gives you information of yes the
winery was established in 1882 yeah it's
a very traditional family wine
[Music]
our wine center has more than 200
members
they are interested in tracing system
they're trying to
make all the chinese market understand
that you can easily enjoy the wine in a
much more safe way
but when we talk about the cost they
think okay it's too much to them three
years ago we use ifid it all
almost cost one yen
for per chips but now if we use the qr
code it's almost maybe 10 cents if we
want more enterprises to join us
we have to lower the cost of the uh
the tap or the chips so in the long term
it kind of evens out the cost and also i
think the real gain is um the assurance
that you can give your customers right i
guess toast to that okay
so now you should bottom up right you
too
[Music]
qr codes cost less which explains why
companies prefer to use this to access
information on their blockchains
the catch is
what if i do this
i make a copy of the qr code
and
or this
[Music]
the url still points to the same link on
the blockchain but the product is
compromised
[Music]
in china blockchain is already playing a
big part in securing the food chain
many food products now come with qr
codes that provide information on where
they come from
but i realize qr codes are far from
foolproof
and if i wanted to i could easily tamper
with the contents
the url still points to the same link on
the blockchain but the product is
compromised
to mitigate this tech entrepreneur yas
palinski came up with a smart packaging
solution
jazz is the co-founder of gualimai a
blockchain startup that imports and
distributes infant formula in china
if you look at the industry right now
there are quite a lot of claims and hype
around blockchain and blockchain will
inevitably solve the problem of fakes
and this is just not the case because
even if happened to scan the fake qr
code it will give you the result of this
record existing on the blockchain and
therefore what's even even worse than
not protecting the product but giving
you a full sense of security in that the
product seems to authenticate with the
blockchain therefore it must be true
and this problem essentially is why
blockchain right now it cannot solve the
problem of fakes on its own and
therefore that needs to be something
extra and okay this is what we're doing
so what's this extra thing that needs to
be done to make blockchain really secure
so this extra thing essentially it's a
physical protection of the of the
product and the physical protection you
need to make sure that there is this
one-to-one correspondence between
blockchain and a physical object
something that you cannot replicate to
an infinite amount of copies
so what we come up with this is uh one
of the older generation of the label but
still works the same
so as you can see here we're protecting
the product not just on the blockchain
in terms of like digital protection but
also physical protection of physical
protection
and so the claim that we're making and
the promise that we are given to our
consumer is that if this thing
authenticates
that means that the product packaging
has not been tampered with i see so what
i see right now is a kind of a cu yeah
um this looks like some kind of
electronic device under the cu so
basically yeah so this is a this is a
label right so it is based on nfc
technology and what you see in the
electronic circuit here is essentially
an antenna which is connected to an nfc
chip as i was doing uh as you could see
this dial kind of filling up with the
percentages you know this is when the
data exchange happened with the
blockchain and all the information has
been checked with a blockchain so this
is what essentially what uh the consumer
says right so this is all all the
standard things so the tracking
logistics information some things about
the product and whatever you want to put
in it okay that's just like a huge list
of uh what what are these actually uh
this uh the scan locations essentially
we use this as our
testing sample so when whenever we have
uh taken it in any of our travels for
demonstrations it would be registered in
the blockchain oh i see as a scanning
event okay oh i see as so anyone who
scans the blockchain also
the data gets uh put on an additional
block gets added every time someone
scans the chip to the
so why is blockchain the way to go for
you so you see we're not the first ones
who try to solve the problem of fakes in
china consumer already lost any sense of
belief in such claims that uh okay so
you're telling me that you're only
selling genuine things but why should i
believe you there are you know 10 other
companies that do the same and they
inevitably fail
and so blockchain in this respect it
works as a meta legitimate for us
because
for us when we use blockchain our the
claim that we make essentially is that
you don't have to trust us you have to
trust the technology so as long as you
understand how the technology works we
don't need to
be
convincing
so here it again it works as a third
party
authenticator for us as a business
babies have died after drinking milk
contaminated with melamine 300 000
others became ill tainted chinese milk
china's baby milk powder scandal fears
are growing around the world over the
safety of chinese milk products
the 2008 milk powder scandal which
killed six babies and left three hundred
thousand others ill
still haunts the chinese
the crisis of confidence worsened when
yet another fake milk scandal was
uncovered in shanghai in late 2015
12 suspects were implicated for passing
off cheap milk powder for branded
products
over twelve thousand cans of branded
milk products were compromised
i am a parent
so knowing whether my milk powder has
been tempered with is absolutely
important
i want to put yaza's product to the test
i'm meeting his sales manager duomo at a
store selling the baby products
what if i tried to peel off the sticker
very carefully and to avoid breaking the
circuit yeah you could try you could try
yeah
okay i'm gonna try
i believe you will you will never i
won't succeed oh it's ruined yeah of
course so this is our physical
protection to prevent any kind of reuse
or recycle for the product but another
thing you need to use your cell phone to
track it again so once you you have tier
or ruin the the level
you couldn't scan anything i see because
the circuit's broken there's no
the antenna is broken so once the
antenna is broken the connection to the
nfc chip is totally broken
[Music]
i left china heartened
not by the state of the technology which
has a long way to go before it gets
adopted by the mainstream
but by the smart and talented men and
women i met committed to using
technology to build a better world
a world where we can trust our food
and that's
why it matters
[Music]
[Music]
you